even though the original civilization
laid the groundwork not just for future
Civ titles but for the strategy genre as
a whole it was essentially a glorified
arms race
you could found cities build world
wonders and unlock new options through
technological research but inevitably
combat played a central role but just
like a real civilization the franchise
evolved over time gradually grafting new
ideas onto its classic framework a
process that's now culminated in
civilization 6 the deepest most well
rounded base game the series has ever
seen there were 7 wonders in the world
and the discovery of the Terracotta Army
when you say is the 8th miracle of the
world more than ever every wind
condition feels equally rich and equally
viable whether you're pursuing culture
religion science or domination you can
build arts districts that allow you to
more quickly accrue culture points and
attract great artists you can create new
religious units like apostles to more
efficiently spread your gospel to the
world you can use the Builder unit in
new ways to better capitalize on the
resources that surround your cities
accelerating humanity's ascent into
space and of course you can still Abbas
a formidable army but even warfare
presents new considerations that force
you to lean on other systems beyond
battle tactics maintaining military
units for example is expensive but
picking trade routes with a high gold
yield helps mitigate the financial
impact war weariness will eventually
lead your population to revolt but using
diplomacy to squeeze luxury resources
out of your allies can quell rebellion
and espionage now deeper than ever lets
you not only play spies but pick
specific missions for them to carry out
Doudna tahoe ii Prachanda espresso ce
que hoy hasta es su guru Singh Yahoo
toast Oh a gig net I sip sex is packed
with added nuances that enrich existing
systems but it also makes some major
changes the biggest of which is
unstacking cities rather than occupy a
single tile on the world map cities now
sprawl outward allowing you to
capitalize on each city's specific
surroundings assuming you exercise some
serious forethought certain structures
for example function more efficiently on
specific types of lands while others can
only be built if certain topographical
demands are met not only does this
change the way you consider the board it
also adds a new strategic layer that
fills a gap and creates greater variety
in the types of thinking Civ demands
[Music]
along with planning each city's long
term development you must also manage
its housing and amenity needs these
replace the global food and happiness
levels of previous civilizations and
make individual turns more engaging in
the process where previously you could
mentally check out for a few turns while
waiting for your big-picture decisions
to pan out you must now actively monitor
and improve each city's condition it can
be a little exasperated and tedious but
ultimately I realized each and every
city contributed to my overall success
and consequently provided unique
opportunities for strategic gain you'll
find a host of slightly smaller but
equally smart changes as well
you can now tailor your government to
your specific playstyle by earning
various policy cards that impact
everything from war weariness to
cultural output civics replaces social
policies and now function identically to
technologies pick one from an expansive
tree spend a few turns researching it
and unlock new cultural possibilities
like theocracy or globalization and with
the addition of active research you can
cut research time in half by meeting
specific logical conditions tied to
individual texts and civics a practice
that ensures an advantage for vigilant
players
smart though these changes maybe they
are accompanied by several notable
imperfections tourism for example is the
metric by which cultural victories are
measured yet the math behind it is
esoteric at best missionaries and other
religious units are similarly opaque
though I did manage a cultural victory
during one match it required some
frustrating trial and error guesswork
and while you could argue that Commerce
and diplomacy facilitate every win
condition it's a shame that neither
serves as a win condition itself perhaps
most crucially opponent AI proved to be
a bit of a mix Catherine Medici was
clever enough to preemptively declare
war against me when she saw my troops
massing at her border and even brought
anti cavalry units to take down my tanks
no CIA sir prese Cleopatra on the other
hand seems you capriciously switch
strategies from religion to domination
and back again and just floundered
uselessly as a result if nothing else
the new agenda system does impute each
leader with a discernible playstyle and
when one denounced me the game
explicitly told me why making diplomacy
a more straightforward affair so I stood
against in amman jordan i guess who came
equipped sub 6 has a few rough edges but
they're pushed far into the periphery by
spectacular strategic depth and
intricate interlocking nuances any
frustrations I experienced were
immediately eclipsed by my desire to
continue playing just one more turn
every turn forever from our humble
beginnings ages ago have you forged the
civilization that has withstood time
itself though countless civilizations
rise and fall around this we do not just
survive
we prosper
[Music]